Well, we're up to chapter 8 and some of my favorite groups, the Adolescents.
We've all survived it.
Let's learn a little bit more about it.
Well, we know one of the biggest things that's happening in Adolescent is this change in physical
maturation.
Basically, our body is going to go through this process of becoming from the child body
to the adult body, which basically means that we're going to start creating sexually mature
bodies.
Now, what is interesting is that when we look at the bodies of young people, the first
things to grow are like their hands, their heads, and their feet.
That's why we sometimes look at boys and they've got these big old clobby feet.
The next bones to grow are going to be your tubular bones, and then finally your trunk.
As we've mentioned before, there is going to be a difference in the growth rate of males
and females.
We know that girls are going to start about two years before boys, and this is just simply
a process of getting that body ready to grow.
Now, at the bottom of this slide, you see basically this chart.
Now, this chart is in your book, and so one of the first things that the genes look at
is that this is the growth per year, and this is the pounds gained per year.
So, each one is showing us something slightly different than the other one.
Now, when we look at the growth per year, and we begin to look at the girls, you can
see that right around here is where we hit the peak, and that's about 12 years of age,
whereas the boys' peak, which is right next to it, is going to happen right around 13
or 14.
Now, that is assuming that a boy or a girl is hitting the normal growth spurt, meaning
is that they aren't a little delayed or a little head.
And then as far as pounds, those tend to follow just before or just after those, so there you
are for the boys, and there are the girls.
Now, again, these charts are to help us understand whether or not somebody is right on target,
or if they're falling behind, or they're even a little bit ahead.
As far as the brain is concerned, we do have brain growth happening at this time, although
as my little picture kind of shows here, sometimes it feels like it's a little bit backward,
but basically, we know the brain is about 95% of its adult size, and we're only going
to grain about another 5% by the end of adolescent.
And remember, for this class, we're looking at adolescent sort of between the ages of
12 and 20.
We do know that the brain of a human kind of grows until about 25 years of age.
Now, one of the things that this slide talks about is this pruning.
And what we're talking about here is that as we are growing up, there's a lot of stuff
that we have in our head.
And then after a while, our head begins to start saying, "Well, do I really need that
information?"
So, our synapses will begin to prune basically a way to things that it does not appear we're
going to need to know or use, which is why you might say at one point you knew all the
capitals of the United States, and now, you know, all those states' capitals, they're
disappearing for you.
But pruning, though, is a way to help us begin to have space for what we begin to specialize
in, you might want to say.
However, the pruning also tends to cause more risky behavior because a lot of times
our inhibitors, they've been, as they say, swamped.
But basically, we have a lack of inhibitors.
Things that right now might make you say, "Don't know about that."
That's sort of what teens may be lacking at this time.
With sexual maturity, we do need to understand the difference between our primary and our
secondary maturations.
Now, primary to me has always been pretty easy to figure out.
Why?
Because if it's a primary item, it means that it has to be there or there's no baby.
So I can ask you, "If I don't have breasts, could I still have a baby?"
And the answer is yes, which means that those are not primary sexual characteristics.
In fact, something like breasts are secondary sexual characteristic.
Could we still have a baby if there was not a scrotum?
And the answer is probably no because we wouldn't have any sperm, thus that's a primary sexual
characteristic.
So that's the easiest way to be able to identify, and yes, on the test, you're going to have
to be able to identify whether something's a primary or secondary sex characteristic.
But keep thinking of it this way.
If it's not there and you can still have a baby, then it's got to be secondary.
But if it's not there, then there's no baby, says there's ovaries, then you know it's going
to be a primary.
Which brings us to sort of the psychological impact of puberty.
And here we really talk more about body image because we are sort of in that physical aspect.
We know that we know teen girls tend to be far more critical about their parents.
And this starts pretty early.
Why?
Because maturation starts early.
So girls who have matured a little bit earlier, they tend to get more attention.
They tend to get more noticed, you might want to say.
They may not be ready for it at 12 or 13, but they get noticed.
So other girls want to go ahead and mature.
So being a late maturing female, quite often, that may make them feel something is wrong
with them.
Why don't they have the right appearance?
With boys, what's kind of interesting is that they tend not to be pleased if their image
of what they think a young man should look like doesn't match what they have.
So he's the image of the young man at 15, 16 and 17.
And he's pretty happy with himself because he's sort of looking what he thinks he should
look like at those age or what he thinks a male body should look like.
Now what is interesting is that the boys will lose this again as they get a little bit older
and girls get a little bit better about body images, they get a little bit older.
One of the hypothesis on why this tends to occur is that we have left sort of this childhood
time and this time that we tended to separate ourselves by gender, meaning the girls tended
to hang out with the girls and the boys tended to hang out with the boys and that now we're
coming back to be sexual creatures and to attract mates you might want to say.
And so both groups want to attract what they consider to be the most successful mate and
thus we are very concerned with how we're going to do that.
And it may be based on our body, it may be based on our finances, but we know that both
groups tend to do this.
So for boys, the interesting thing is is that if they don't match your rate early, if they
tend to be a late matcherator, that tends to have a much greater psychological negative
impact on them than girls.
While girls may not be happy about not maturing early, they don't seem to suffer as most consequences
for that.
In fact for girls, maturing too early can be the problem because a 12 year old with bosoms
quite often gets hit upon and she's not psychologically ready to be considered a sexual object yet.
But the truth is from the outside world a lot of people don't know this is a 12 year
old because she has a full bosom and then they think oh she must be older than she is.
So for boys, a little younger is good to maturing for girls a little older.
Which brings us to moodiness.
Now almost all the people when I first ask them they'll say oh moodiness is because of
the hormones but I want you to look at that last bullet right there, increased and rapid
increase in hormones is generating greater irritability and impulse but it is not moodiness.
Oops, that just completely took it away, let me take that away.
But it is not moodiness.
Basically moodiness in teens comes more from the fact that they are now being challenged
to do things they haven't done before.
Their social activities are changing more, their response of more for things.
I always remember my nephew who joked about the magic closet and his joke was that when
he was younger the magic closet this always seemed to be full of things so when he needed
a toilet paper he opened up the magic closet was there and when he toothpaste he opened
up the closet and it was there and that as he got older that magic closet wasn't working
so well and one day he opened a magic closet and there was no toilet paper, no deodorant,
no toothpaste, no anything and he kind of turned to his mother and he said where is
everything and she said I don't know when was the last time he went shopping.
So he of course got very irritated and was all moody about that and he says he kind of
distinctly remembers this because to him as he called it the magical closet and he said
oh well do he realize that you know he was old enough to go shopping at that point but
all of a sudden he had this new responsibility he didn't have before, before it just filled
up by itself.
So moodiness is not about hormones, moodiness is more about this change in activity, this
change in what we have an expectation of, the hormones may increase our irritability
and being more impulsive but it's not moodiness.
Now we talk about rates of maturation, basically early maturator and boys are around 11 and
girls are 9, yes we do have girls who maturate at 9, later maturations for boys are 15 or
16 and girls for 14 or 50.
Now the effect of the sexual activity of these people will vary among ethnic groups.
We know that in many areas of Asia you see late maturating for both girls and boys.
You may have noticed in the Olympics when you see a female gymnast you're like I cannot
believe that female gymnast is 16 she looks like she's 12 or maybe you've seen some sort
of a spelling competition and there's a young boy who steps up and you can hardly believe
that that boy is in eighth grade because he looks so young but it really does sort of
depend on your ethnic background and it's even more than your ethnic background it's
really your genetic background.
So your rate of maturation is really more of a nature rather than a nurture aspect.
If you found that your parents maturated early there's a good chance you're going to
maturate early and of course if your parents maturated later there's a good chance you're
going to maturate later.
With nutrition we do have girls having to sort of get down to that 2,000 calories a day
and the boys they get a little bit more 27.
What we do find is that they need extra iron especially boys for muscles and girls but they
both also need calcium.
What happens is that this time they may stop drinking calcium milk or getting calcium from
other areas and so they may lag in calcium for what they need.
The biggest problem with teens is that quite often they are beginning to get more calories
per day than they actually need because of the foods that they are eating outside of
perhaps the home which brings us to obesity.
Now BMI body mass index is basically a measurement of your height versus your weight and there
is a number that we like people to shoot for.
At teens we begin to find that we're going to really have some issues you might say with
obesity.
What we also know though is that it may be among the easiest time for them to lose this
extra weight.
They tend to have more opportunities to be physically active.
They tend to have more opportunities to watch what the nutrition they are eating but it
can be also very hard because a lot of their friends are eating other foods.
This whole process of losing weight is not one that is an easy for any age.
But for teens it may even have a greater social issue for them and because overweight teens
tend to be less popular and they tend to be made fun of and you can see this in TV shows
and stuff like this it can also lead to isolation for these individuals.
On the other hand we have the eating disorders where people don't eat anorexia.
Now one of the big things is that a lot of times when we talk about anorexia we tend
to think of this as a girl's disease.
But notice in the little chart over there that while there's 3% of girls who do get an
orexia or bulimia 1% of boys also develop this.
And recently it tends to be showing a little bit higher trending for boys.
Boys may even be up to 2% more on the anorexia side than they are on the bulimia side.
Now anorexia is sort of this fear being overweight.
They often have this unbelievable vision of who they believe they are.
So from back from inner introduction to psychology we talked about Carl Rogers and you talked
about the ideal self, the true self and the self image.
Now as those images all change basically they do not match.
We begin to find that teens will do something to try to make them match.
Unfortunately this is where the anorexia may come in because the girl or the young boy
may look in the mirror and think that they are heavy and they need to lose more weight.
But often they don't start out to be anorexics and in fact quite a lot of times people don't
realize they are anorexics for quite a long time.
If you look at the image of that young lady and you look at the image of that young man.
If they have clothes on you may not even notice just how thin they are.
Their faces look pretty normal.
She just looks a little thin on the face.
He just looks a little thin on the face.
It's only once they take off their clothes.
Do you begin to see just how thin they are?
So put a pair of sweatpants on her and a sweatshirt and you wouldn't notice it.
In fact for the guy if he puts on kind of a bulky t-shirt even with those shorts he doesn't
show his legs in this particular image it may not be too hard to see.
Now one of the things about anorexia as far as young men are concerned and why there's
a hypothesis that's increasing in boys is sort of this image that we now have of the
popular young man.
For girls we've always had this image of this you know thin young woman.
In fact the saying is to be saying that you're going to be too young or too thin.
But luckily today in fashion in many other areas we're beginning to see women of normal
weight.
But for young men it's kind of gone the other way around.
Where we used to see guys who are a little soft maybe even a tad bit pudgy as being you
know sort of sexy and sex symbols.
Today we see guys who are really ripped who have got big six packs.
And so if we're talking to a young man and he wants to look really ripped one of the
problems is that not only does he have to develop the muscles but he has to have very
little to no body weight on him to be able to see those muscles.
So when you see some of these stars or some of these athletes who look really ripped all
the time first of all they quite often exercise just before they were to go on camera and get
their picture taken.
It can also be spray tanned in a little bit to make it more dramatic.
But they also have gotten way down in body fat because the body fat hides those rippling
muscles.
So if I'm a young man and I think I want to get that six pack I'm going to have to become
pretty thin in order for that six packs to show.
Balemia on the other hand is eating and purging.
Now eating and purging sort of concept quite often is done because of stress.
And the stress is unbearable you might want to say in their life.
And so they eat because hey you know it's time to eat and I don't feel good and eating
is a fun activity.
I mean chocolate tastes good pizza tastes good and as they show in this particular scenario
here with some of the common symptoms of bulimia we can also have very limited time to eat.
So I'm trying to eat the car I'm trying to eat here so when I do eat I eat too much.
But after I eat all this I begin to feel bad because I might be a little overweight
already or I need to stay thin.
And so what I'm going to do is I'm going to go and purge the food.
And that purging that makes you feel good because you ate to feel good but then you feel
bad and when you purge all that badness comes back out of you.
And so it becomes this sort of cycle of eating and purging.
Unfortunately there are websites that are actually dedicated to supposedly healthy bulimia
and healthy anorexia there is no such thing as healthy of either one of these.
I read a story once of a lady who is a bulimic and she had been for most of her life and
at one point she gets pregnant.
And she talks about how she got through bulimia with her pregnancy because she wanted her
child to be healthy and what she would do is she would eat her meal and then she would
eat a lot of carrots because she felt that if she got up in the middle of the night and
had one of her sort of attacks she had to go eat more food because she was just so stressed.
And then when she'd go through her up she would throw up until she saw carrots.
And when she saw the carrots she knew she had to stop because the rest of the food in
that system had to go to the child.
So some of this bulimia is really well calculated almost well thought out.
So if you think about a high pressure person or a big star or something like this they
know they have to go out to a dinner party pretty soon they're feeling very anxious so
they eat a little something because they don't want to look like they're going to overeat
at the dinner party because everybody would look oh look how much she ate.
So she eats a little bit there and then she goes to the party and she gets a little nervous
and she has some appetizers and then she has some of this and then she has some dessert
because everyone's like oh I have this wonderful dessert and so when she comes home she's beginning
to feel really bad because now she's overeating and so she'll throw up.
It gets to be the cycle of eating and purging which can be really really hard for some people
to break.
When we talk about threats to adolescents one of the biggest things we need to talk about
is this illusion of invulnerability.
Now we'll talk a little bit more about this when we get to chapter 9 but basically what
we know is that for teens they tend to think of themselves as being invulnerable things
aren't going to happen to them so they will take risks that other people wouldn't take.
In fact the World Health Organization at one point said the most dangerous thing about
being a teen is being male because they did such risky behaviors because they just didn't
feel like they were going to hurt themselves but the serious thing we also need to talk
about is suicide and for many of you you may not have guessed that Native Americans were
the most likely to commit suicide in their teens.
In fact while this chart might be a little outdated it is significant among Native Americans.
In the little print that is down in this area right here notice that it said that even the
Native American population may be under reported by up to 30 percent.
That means is that while we say 3.4% of all suicides are from Native Americans it could
actually be a lot higher and notice Native American males and some people may say well
why are Native American males more likely to commit suicide there are several reasons
one the reservations are really depressing places to live.
If you've been to a true reservation we're not talking about the Florida ones we're
talking about the ones that are out west.
Some of these places haven't ever had running water they have to truck in water actually
from the outside there is no future for them there there is no hardly any education for
them there and then when they come off the reservations the world looks at them differently
perhaps we look at things like how they're portrayed in movies or even symbols so a lot
of you may have heard the controversy about whether the Washington Red Skin should change
their names because Native Americans find this very offensive to be called a Red Skin
or the Indians as a baseball team and their comment is is would you ever have a baseball
team called the Caucasians and the answer is probably not or the Blacks we probably wouldn't
do that either but it's okay to have the Indians and I want to get back to Red Skins
for a moment because I learned this later on the question came why are they called Red
Skins and people think it's because their skin is perhaps a little darker or more red
color and that's not it at all it comes back from when Europeans first came to the United
States and we know that there were a lot of Native Americans of course already living
here and we wanted the same space as them and so when the Indians and the Europeans you
might want to say started to fight we put out basically bounties and one of the things
that came out to be is that in order for you to get the money for killing a Native American
you had to bring in basically their scalp while it was still red meaning is that we still
had red it was still pink it was fresh because that they didn't want people doing is digging
up graves and taking the scalps from there so they had to be Red Skins in order for you
to get your reward so you see where we see Red Skins is not a big thing for them it basically
represents a time period when they were hunted and killed and they don't see it as a fun
loving you might say logo so they have a lot of interesting things to deal with here in
the United States and because suicide may be a little bit more acceptable within their
culture also we see really high rates of suicide among Native Americans so let's come to this
the brain of teens one of the things that we have to understand is that teen brains are
almost like adult brains and in many ways they are adult brains one of the things that's
really interesting and there's a chart in your book to look at for this is when people first
look at this chart about processing speed that you see there you think the processing
speed is going down because you see a downward slope and so you think oh that's getting slower
but if we really think about it the downward slope actually means speeding up so we're going
from 500 to 200 which means it's going faster by about 12 we pretty much picked up what speed
we're gonna have we don't see dramatic changes now yes we're still gonna get a little faster
from 12 to 21 but the speed of or the increase in speed is much more minor compared to the
increase of speed from 0 to 12 years of age so already by the time we're hitting maturation
we've got pretty much our basic speed what we do know is that at this point children will
have used heuristics so this rule of thumb if it's like this it must be like that don't
forget these are concrete thinkers when we talk about children but by the time we're
adolescents we are in the formal operation stage which means that we have the ability
to think in abstract and if we're have the ability to think in abstract we have the ability
to begin to have analytical thought and use logical analysis so kids who may have just
done things because that's how it's got to be done adolescents will begin to question
and challenge these things they're kind of skill defining weaknesses and flaws or reasoning
because they haven't really had to do that before so here's where the the young adolescent
will argue back with you in something you might say something like you need to go do
your homework now because if you don't you won't finish high school and they say oh I'll
finish high school because I've got to be in my class and all you need is a D to get
out so I don't really have to worry about doing that homework see they see a weakness
in that argument because they know they only need a D and yet there have a B at this point
and one little homework to them doesn't mean that they're going to fail the class now they
will use heuristics just like you do everyone's want to say good enough that's that's it and
you can think about some of the work that you've done even some of the homework you're
going to do at one point you might say you know it's enough there it's done and you move
on and you may or may not look up something in the textbook it will be up to you to make
that decision but what we want you to understand in this lecture is that this is sort of how
teens look to sometimes you're going to get into detail and sometimes you're just going
to go buy your rule of thumb now the last thing we're really going to cover in this is
Kohlberg now I wish we had a picture of Kohlberg I could put in but it just didn't quite fit
on this slide now Kohlberg is pretty interesting here and I notice that my Kohlberg slide only
says level one and two it's level one two and three because he is probably the predominant
way we look at moral reasoning development in young people the one thing though with Kohlberg
is that for this class I want you to understand the levels I don't want you to really memorize
the stages so these levels and the names of these levels which is why they are in orange
are the ones that you would be tested on now the stages are important right here but what
I have found is that in some of the classes or some of your particular programs when you
get into them they might have slightly different names for the levels the stages but the levels
are always the same there's no changing the levels names so we're going to focus a little
more on the levels than the actual stages I'll talk a little bit about those so let's
go over here to good old level one now level one right here we like to say it's pre-conventional
and it's all about punishment and reward so I'm going to use a stop sign as an example
as a stage one it's four o'clock in the morning you come to a stop sign it's a four
way stop but you already know that one of the ways there's absolutely nothing there there's
no houses there's it's a dead-end road and if you go to the left there's one house on
that road so really it's only somebody coming to the right but yet it's a four way stop
sign it's four o'clock in the morning and you know there's going to be nobody else there
because you're the one who lives in the one house that's on the left but you stop and
you stop because you say to yourself you know if I don't I know there's going to be a cop
behind that tree and they're gonna give me a ticket and I just got to stop because I
just can't afford a ticket right now so you've obeyed because you're trying to avoid punishment
you might want to say you've obeyed because of an authority figure so we might call that
a stage one where we might find those of you who are adults and have kids you've had this
happen to you you're sitting on the couch on nice and happy like and your little kid comes
out and they start to pretend to massage your shoulders or at least they try and you're
like oh thank you very much honey what is it that you want why are they massaging your
soldiers because you know they want something and it's their nice behavior in order to hopefully
get some sort of future favor now according to kohlberg young kids won't get past that
stage while they're young the next stage of development in moral development the conventional
tends to start happening around our teens in fact it's surges in our teens what he says
is that at some point we begin to make decisions because we think it is socially accepted norm
so coming back to that expectation of the stop sign in the middle of the night you come
to the stop sign and now you say well even though I think this is really silly that there's
a stop sign here in order to maintain basically the rules of the road I should stop because
if I don't stop then the next person's not going to stop but the next person's not going
to stop and then all of a sudden we have chaos and a lot of crashes so to maintain the order
or social order of this world I will stop I may do a California stop and kind of roll
it but I'm going to slow down I'm not going to just speed through it because if I do it
then it's going to break the rules and then we'll have traffic suggestions rather than
traffic laws so he would say that's conventional you're doing your decision making based on
social rules teens do a lot of this they look at what their friends are doing what other
people are doing and they tend to make decisions you know are you going to go do this well I
don't know I got to see what Aidan's going to do Mary may come out and be dressed in
one way why are you dressed that way well because Stevie and Cindy and Larry are all going to
get dressed like this so I feel like I have to get dressed this way why are you participating
in this event well my friends are doing it so they're living up to these expectations
that others have now the last one the post conventional it basically says that not everybody
is going to reach this and by the way not everyone is making every decision only on
one level you can be an adult and one point like stopping at the stop sign you're using
a level one and a few minutes later you could be using a level three decision it's about
the actual moral decision more than what your age is he just cold work just believe that
young kids couldn't get past level one and that it's in your adolescence where level
two begins to develop level three he says can develop in your adolescence but maybe a little
later in your adolescence when you've got a little more brain development and he calls
a post conventional moral codes now here we have to be a little bit careful when we hear
moral codes most of us think we have our own moral codes and the truth is that you probably
really don't have as much of a personal moral code as you think a lot of our moral codes
have been decided within our culture we've kind of come to a decision that that this
is a moral code like don't kill somebody is a commonly shared moral code what he's talking
about here is when you might be willing to go against the social contract of moral codes
so I always like to use the lovings now the lovings were a couple in the sixties who went
to Washington DC and got married the thing is that one was black and one was white and
they went back to Virginia where they lived in Virginia it was against the law for a black
and a white person to marry so they broke the moral code they did not feel it was valid
that their skin color should dictate whether or not they could be a married couple so they
did not adhere to the social contract that only the same race people should marry they
said they don't think this is valid thus they broke that moral social contract you might
want to say because their moral code said that this was not a correct thing and there
are many times you may have not gone along with social moral codes because you did not
feel it was valid the last one in stage six now that one's a little bit harder he says
there aren't many people like that and they really aren't we say a personal moral system
based on an abstract principle now the key there is going to be the words abstract principle
now this doesn't mean that you know you've made up a moral code and thus I've got an abstract
principle and he's talking about what principle drove your moral code so the best one I can
use is somebody know who's a pretty strong vegan if you understand veganism it's not
just about not eating animals it is in this case for her the fact that she truly believes
that animals who are not put on this earth for us to take advantage of them that we have
developed in society that there is no reason for us to take advantage of an animal so it's
more than just not eating the animals it would also be not writing an animal after all we
have cars she says so why should I ride a horse when I've got a car there's no reason to force
a horse to you know carry me she will not buy any type of product that has leather in it
there is no reason for her to use the skin of somebody else for her own comfort as she
would say is as we would use the skin of humans to make a handbag what makes it okay to use
the skin of a cow to make a handbag she quit her job after a while because her job wasn't
a restaurant and the restaurant served meat and she said she simply could not continue
to work in a restaurant which basically went against her basic moral principles so she
took a job with a company that was to promote healthy animals and the health of animals and
she spends her weekends protesting farms she is saving her money to buy a sanctuary so she
can rescue turkeys and she can rescue pigs and other animals like that that are being
brought to the slaughterhouse she has a personal modal moral system that's based on an abstract
principle that basically we are more sophisticated than animals and as such we should not use
animals to help us live because we have grown beyond that type of technology that's what
he's talking about with stage six and he says there are a whole lot of people that get to
that stage now we do have to understand that different cultures will have different types
of moral systems and look at it differently kohlberg he tended to look at justice he also
tended to only ask young men so there are many other kinds of moral development people out
there that we tend to look at um kohlberg i've picked because he is so predominant you
might want to say in the studies that we have here in the medical world and in the studies
that we have sort of in the united states however we do know is that kohlberg stages
are not universal while his things do tend to go toward western philosophies and the religions
of the western world they don't exactly adhere to many the other religions and if we want
to think about um they give you hindu here but napal um if we go to napal which is a rather
religious place but more in Confucianism um which is not really a religion it's a philosophy
you would not find that his moral groups you might want to say would apply to that however
for this class we do want you to know those four levels of kohlberg well that's the end
of chapter eight if you have any questions give me an email and i will respond have a good one people